what is your book titled goodness
paradox what are the main ideas in this
book
well the paradox is the fact that humans
uh show
extremes embellish
in relationship to both violence and
non-violence
and so the
um
the violence is that we are one of these
few animals in which we
uh use coalitionary proactive violence
to kill members of our own species and
we do it in large numbers just like a
few other species
and the
non-violence is were particularly
extreme in
how
repressed we are in terms of reactive
violence and i i told you the story of
of how we get there you know so what's
so extraordinary about us is that
uh most animals
are either high on both or relatively
low on both
so chimpanzees are high on proactive
violence and reactive violence bonobos
are less
than
chimpanzees on both of those but still
hundreds of times more
reactively aggressive than humans are
what we've done is retain uh proactive
violence being high and
got
reactive violence really being low
and so we have these wonderful societies
in which we're all so incredibly nice to
each other and tolerant and calm and and
can meet strangers and have no problem
about um
leading to any kind of uh conflict
at the same time as we are one of the
worst uh killing machine species that's
ever existed so what's so extraordinary
about this is that if you look at the
political philosophers of the last few
hundred years
you've got this fight
famously between thomas hobbes and
jean-jacques rousseau or literally
you've got the fight between their
followers
you know so the followers of hobbs say
well hobbes was right because he says
that we are naturally violent and you
need a leviathan a central government or
king to be able to suppress the violence
so we're naturally hurried and we can
learn to be good whereas jean-jacques
rousseau is interpreted as saying the
opposite that we are naturally good and
it's only when culture intervenes and
and horry like your ideologies come in
that we become uncivilized and so people
have have had this endless fight between
are we naturally
corrupt or are we naturally
kind
and and that has gone on you know for
years and it's only in the last two or
three decades that anthropologists like
christopher baume and bruce naft have
said look you know it's obvious what the
answer is we are both of these things
and what is so exciting now is i think
we can understand why we are both and
the answer is we come from
ancestors that were elevated on
proactive aggression that were
hunters and killers
both of animals and of each other
and you've got to include that as almost
certain
uh from the past
and um and then now we've we've
taken our reactive aggression and we've
down regulated it and that's given us
power it's given us power because
once you get rid of the alpha male once
the beta males take over and
force selection in favor of a more
tolerant less reactively aggressive
individual
the effect is
that our cultures suddenly become
capable of focusing on things other than
conflict
and so we have social groups in which
individuals instead of constantly being
on edge in the way that chimpanzees are
with each other
um
are able to interact
in ways that enable them to share
looking at a tool together or share
their food together or
pass ideas from one to another or
support each other when they're ill or
whatever the issue is cooperate in ways
that make the group far more effective
so you asked earlier you know what did i
think about why
sapiens was able to expand at the
expense of neanderthals so dramatically
around 40 000 years ago
and the answer is uh that
whatever it was it had something to do
with the sapiens ability to cooperate
that was what gave them bigger groups
that's what enabled them to
have a far more effective way of living
and i suspect it was to do with the
weapons and and military aspects but
even if it wasn't that that the
greater cooperation that
sapiens were showing
uh would have been hugely important so
sapiens then had groups of uh
you know who knows exactly how big they
were but um
uh uh scores of of people uh to judge
from their remains uh whereas
neanderthals were living in
widely separated small groups of you
know maybe maybe as many as 15 or 20
people sometimes
where they saw others so rarely that
they were in breeding at high levels you
know fathers uh having babies with their
daughters
very different world
very different world and that's probably
what our world was like before we got
sapiens before we got serpents and it's
fascinating that there was that kind of
violence against so
once you get the
get rid of the alpha males
you have now the freedom to uh
to have kindness amongst the beta
the beta males like not not kindness but
collaboration that's the better word yes
right
right much more correlation not just
among the males but among the females
but also among the gamma males and the
uh and the females yeah
i don't know what a gamma male is but i
imagine there's a whole alphabet
well i don't know about hello enough but
i think the the big letters are the
married men yeah and and the and the
unmarried men ah you know because now
the married men were had a problem with
the unmarried men
right i mean you you see it in
ethnographies of hunters and gatherers
recently where uh the unmarried men
would be given rules such as i mean the
very extreme rule in northern australia
was uh you cannot come to the camp uh
for months you have to go away and live
uh somewhere out in the bush yes because
we don't want you anywhere near our
wives
and uh and then another kind of you know
rule is um if you are in the camp you
must be in the fire light all the time
otherwise we don't know what you're
doing out in the dark
so your real efforts to control them
because you know
the men who had lots of wives did not
want those horrid bachelors sneaking
around
i love this
you also wrote the book titled catching
fire how cookie made us human
what's the central idea in this book
the subtitle how cooking made us human
refers not to homo sapiens but to homo
erectus
so human there means the genus homo
and homo erectus is the first
full member of the genus homo in the
sense that
it looked like us just with a
sort of slightly robust more robust
build and a
smaller brain
i and the central idea of catching fire
is that it was the
control of fire
that
was responsible for the emergence of
homo erectus
and therefore the genus homo
which happened two million years ago
and it was
a
an evolution from a
um a line of australopithecines
and australopithecines are the creatures
with which um
from from whom
we evolved
they
were present in africa
from something like
six or seven million years ago
up to
actually up to one million years ago
and then a branch
led off to homo around 2 million years
ago
and the way to think of
australopithecines
is that they were like chimpanzees
standing upright
so they were erect bipedal walkers
they were like chimpanzees in the sense
that
they had brains about the size of a
chimpanzee they were literally about the
body size of a chimpanzee a little bit
smaller actually
and they had big jaws because they were
still eating
raw food they had
big teeth and big jaws
and then around 2 million years ago
the line of australopithecines which
ended with a
an intermediate species a kind of
missing link area because it's not
missing called um
habilis uh
sometimes called homo habilis but more
properly i in my view call
australopithecus habilis
that
gave rise to homo erectus and homo
erectus here's how different it was
it had
a smaller mouth
a smaller jaw
smaller teeth
and to judge from its ribs and pelvis
smaller gut
in addition
it had lost what australopithecines all
had which was adaptations for climbing
in the trees
and that meant that homo erectus must
have slept on the ground
and since it slept on the ground
it should have been able to defend
itself somehow against predators and i
can't think of any way they could have
done that unless they had fire
so
there are two major clues to why
it was
with homo erectus
that our ancestors first acquired the
control of fire
one is the fact that they were clearly
not sleeping in trees in the way that
chimpanzees and gorillas and bonobos and
all the other primates do
and the other is that there was this
striking reduction throughout the gut
reduction in size of the mouth and the
chewing apparatus
and in the gut itself
and
that
conforms to what we see nowadays about
humans which is that our guts are about
two-thirds of the size of what they
would be if we at raw food
to judge by
the great apes
so
at some point in our revolution
we
acquired
the skill of cooking and skill of
controlling fire
at no time
between two million years ago and the
present do we see any changes in our
anatomy
that can as it were justify
the
enormous change that happens when
you are an animal that learns to control
fire
but at 2 million years ago we have
exactly what you'd expect namely the
guts becoming smaller because the food
is becoming softer and much more easy to
digest so you don't have to work so hard
in your body to digest it
and as i say
um
commitment to sleeping on the ground
which i think you'd be absolutely crazy
to do nowadays uh on a moonless night uh
in the middle of serengeti unless you
had fire i've slept out quite a lot in
various parts of africa uh in the bush
and you will not catch me just lying on
the ground um in an area with lots of
predators unless i got a fire with me
you're going to get eaten
you're going to get terrified and you're
going to get eaten
okay so there's a million questions i
want to ask so one
is it very naturally coupled the
discovery of controlled fire and
cooking with fire is that an obvious
leap
well
what here's what we know we know that um
all the animals that we've tested like
to eat their food cooked more than they
like it raw okay so this is true for all
the great apes you know we've tested
them
um that's fascinating by the way
why is that that's just like a property
of food i suppose yes i think what it is
is that um
animals are always looking for any kind
of way to get food that is easier to
digest
and there are various signals in the
food such as the amount of sugar there
the amount of free amino acids because
the amino acids can be tasted um
and the physical qualities of the food
be particularly important how tough the
food is always prefer softer food
provided it it feels safe you know it
tastes safe
and these kinds of uh sensory cues
uh are
all there in cooked food
you know it's uh it's soft it doesn't
have so many uh toxins it's not so
noxious to taste um easier to chew so
everyone loves it spontaneously
your dogs and your cats prefer cooked
food to raw food well maybe you can say
that's a consequence of domestication
but even you know as i say all the great
apes
you test naive ones and uh they prefer
it cooked if they can so uh so then
obvious once you have fire you're going
to accidentally discover that
food changes when you apply fire to it
and then there's going it's going to be
the crea the big crazy new fad yeah you
took the words out of my mouth i mean if
if they have fire at all and you know
their food rolls into it
five minutes later it tastes better than
before
uh
how big of an invention from an
engineering perspective do you think is
the discovery of fire
do you do you think um
for the
uh for homo erectus homo sapiens do you
think it's the greatest invention ever
yeah
i think i think that
that
uh the control of fire
has
been ultimately responsible for
essentially uh
how grandiose do i want to be here you
know the entire human story uh going
back to homo is what changed us from
being a regular kind of animal
and
perhaps the biggest way in which it is
likely to have changed us is it reduced
the difficulty of making a large brain
so
uh you know the story here is that
the constraints on brain size
are energetic
you and i have brains that are something
like
2.5
of our body weight
it consumes around 25 percent of all of
our calories
so it's disproportionate
there are other expensive organs in our
body as well such as the heart
and
what's different about their brain is
that in addition to us being able to
fuel it in a way that other animals
can't
we also have reasons for wanting to have
an even bigger brain whereas we don't
want an even bigger heart
so what those reasons are is unclear but
um
with regard to the
costs of maintaining a brain
cooking makes it possible because it's
supplying
um more calories
and it is enormously reducing the amount
of time that it takes to chew your food
so if you were a gorilla
and you wanted to have a bigger brain
you might say okay well let's just eat
some more
but gorillas are eating
for
pretty much the entire day in the sense
that
they are eating for
maybe seven or eight hours a day in some
seasons
that's just chewing and then they've got
to sit around and digest their food
because they can't just eat all the time
they've got to
take a break while the food is
digested in the stomach and then passed
into the gut
so the stomach is already full
so basically gorillas are eating about
the maximum rate already
so how does a gorilla get a bigger brain
it doesn't it's actually got a smaller
brain relative to his body size than
chimpanzee does
and
and that's the basic problem for our
ancestors
then you come along and cook and all of
a sudden you can get an increased amount
of energy from your food
you are spending much less energy on
digesting your food
you know there are
25 bodily processes or more that are
involved in digesting your food making
the acid that
takes the proteins apart
maintaining the brush border where the
molecules are taken across the gut wall
and so on
that all costs it costs you to digest
your food it costs less if you cook your
food so you get a net gain in the amount
of energy
and you are reducing the amount of time
from
uh in our case of our ancestors probably
around 50 of the day
to chewing two nowadays
one hour a day chewing
so all of a sudden you've got hours a
day in which to do other things and to
use those those brains that you've now
enabled to grow so with homo erectus you
start the process of getting a bigger
brain and famously you know throughout
the whole period of the evolution of the
genus homo you have a steadily
increasing size of brain
until
right at the end when it actually gets
it actually gets
you